reykjavik the capital of iceland
the island nation doesn't have a long
tradition of design but over the past
few years that's been changing
of the icelandic design center
says there's a rising demand for
homegrown products
people perhaps have been more interested
in icelandic design they want to wear it
they think it's great they're proud of
it
so p so icelanders look at it more and
i mean
perhaps we were not thinking a lot about
it like in 2007 or 2006. it's not that
we didn't like it we're just focusing on
other things
fashion designer berg throughout the
dauter has successfully survived the
economic crisis
in 2005 she and her husband started
their farmer's market label which draws
on the country's knitting tradition
their reinterpretation of traditional
icelandic woolen jumpers hasn't just
found success on the island but also in
the rest of europe japan and the us
when i started doing fashion or
designing
some years ago
there was not so so many icelandic
designers actually working in iceland so
but now there are quite many and people
have more selection
in recent years a number of new
boutiques have opened in reykjavik
devoted to icelandic design
anyone looking for branches of major
international fashion stores on the
capitol's main shopping street will be
disappointed
places like sparks gallery sell many
creations by young designers
is on her way to the oldest house in the
city
it's home to a shop called chrome which
since 2007 sells only icelandic products
i think we are in the stage where
the designers are exploring our roots
quite a lot our materials and
and our heritage
and drawing forth interesting stories
and materials into their design so
from my point of view we are in quite an
interesting period right now
a few hundred meters away is the aurum
boutique with adjacent studio
the work on sale here is inspired by
iceland's nature
jewelry designer both bjork christine
engras daughter works mostly with silver
and her customers include hollywood star
matt damon
she too came through the 2008 crisis
unscathed
actually
at the same time i was expanding i was
making myself bigger at that time so i
worry a little bit what what happened
but i
i just have got more customers
the new design quarter is centered
around the capital's former fishing
harbor
several icelandic designers have moved
in and set up studios with shops
such as fashion label stainlen
next door zigemus is hard at work she's
one of the country's most successful
designers the swedish furniture chain
ikea is among her clients
like many of their fellow icelandic
designers she studied and worked abroad
she only came back three years ago
people are very open-minded and there's
very short distance to everyone if you
want to make a prototype or if you want
to do something or collaborate you only
with one phone call you have it done
that's not how it works in sweden
to further local design the iceland
academy of arts is offering a course in
product and textile design
previously young icelanders had to go
abroad to study design and many stayed
away after graduating
hartha helger wants to see an increase
in the number of home-grown designers
icelandic music scene has emerged very
much during the last 20 to 30 years and
it's a reality we have we have
internationally acknowledged music
musicians
so why not designers
and who knows iceland's star designers
of tomorrow might be sitting right here
you